[Music]
[Applause]
now do I want a classic grave or one of
those tiny marble houses oh I can see
myself in a little Taj Mahal but less
ethnic I can't predict if Indians are
still going to be trendy in a hundred
years Oh Beatrice look I can get pink
satin in my casket ooh and a monogrammed
pillow
Beatrice help me pick my death pose do
you think this is too old-fashioned oh
maybe arms by my side that's more modern
Oh
or maybe something like what does it
matter
worms are gonna eat you either way may I
help you I will take two of your finest
applause preferably in an area that can
accommodate a crowd wonderful well that
should save me the time of going through
this extremely extensive waiting list
please I'm sure there's something we can
do
it's very important that I'm buried here
oh it's very important well why didn't
you say so in that case all you need to
do is travel backwards in time and get
your great-great-great grandparents to
have better families and improve their
bloodlines that is if they can even
speak English we don't know how to
travel backwards in time you should tell
that to your dresses that might hurt our
feelings if anything you said mattered
but we're all just animals on a cold
unfeeling rock hurtling our way toward
the inevitable godless abyss so it
doesn't fine they're still old dresses
please you don't understand
hello child I do I do I simply don't
care anyway there's nothing to be done
the cemetery's completely booked we're
only accepting in legacies now oh so
legacies are guaranteed admission yes
how else do you think we ended up with a
mule ATO district now if you'll excuse
me my 4:00 o'clock is here
Oh mr. Needham welcome I see you brought
your parents come let's go pick out some
plots for your grandchildren
I want the money I want the fame I want
the whole world to know my name